hey forgot to mention something super
duper important for you Marvel fans the
three of us are going to be having a
Comic-Con panel that's right a real
rejects panel at this year's Comic-Con
Marvel might not be there they got too
intimidated once they heard that we were
showing up more details of date and time
of when it's all going to go down what's
going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch episode dose
of secret Envision Jean how are you
[Music]
terrible yes and koi do better uh
all right yeah you are French
ladies and gentlemen you know what to do
invade that like button do it and also
subscribe click that notification Bell
get notified when our next reaction for
secret evasion is up here on the Chanel
and as always if you want to sync up
with us full-length Reaction watch
launchers with your own copy of secret
evasion available for super sexy Rejects
at our patreon page thank you to all who
have joined our patreon cover a bunch of
stuff exclusively over there as well
let's swing no action people
[Music]
still in the 90s
where's that needle drop
welcome I'd like you to meet someone
this is graphic you son of a kill
him
piloted a ship all on his own he is
smart Fury knows how to survive we could
use someone like him hire further faster
baby
if I don't deliver on my promise create
an alliance against me
this work here
you know it's very dangerous
I'm not afraid
I can see you're not
good talk for those of you who braved
the journey here to Earth you did so for
one reason
this man
oh
Nicholas the world
is facing a serious threat and I could
use your help putting on a new face and
keeping it this
is the promise not about it while you
work to keep my home safe we'll find you
a new one what a fascinating ask you
keep your word
I'll keep mine I'm gonna think about
that for a second
[Music]
homeboy feels hurt
oh
woof not even Nick could tell I was him
he's losing his Edge
foreign
they've gone
the new Marvel cap
yeah
[Laughter]
the one time she said
I mean something I don't know about you
and Susie
me and Susie had a standing game of
doctor oh man Susie saw a bullfrog with
polka dots my mama just
told her everything she needed to know
it's an allegory
oh you want to go for your rounds sure
tell me something I don't know about the
destruction of Scrolls
you know
everything I believe you they're here
there's a million Scrolls walking
amongst us right now and every scroll
that isn't in Emperor George's colony
hi to me hmm
I could let my people be annihilated or
summon them here to Earth what would you
have done this ain't about me all right
but you find using us as your spies and
your air in boys as long as it's on your
terms
here it is because you were gone and you
know what even when you did come back
there was no talking to you about
anything real
your boots barely hit Earth
My Hope Is that with your help this
Crossing humans can co-exist here on
Earth can't coexist what are you trying
to say love
we've been at war with each other since
we could walk upright there's not enough
room or Tolerance on this planet for
another species
I think this is just a
what
don't you need him to cover for you it's
nice that they have two Powerhouse
actors and they're letting them
demonstrate that power yeah absolutely
they're both incredible cinemarvel I'm
so glad this is a show not a movie we
would not get those kind of movies the
movies are the worst no but we get six
hours instead of like two how did it
happen
quickly don't you be one of those
bastards who gives me a platitude when
I'm looking for the truth
she died in Moscow
we were there trying to stop the attack
someone said a trap Mama Hill
someone wanted
to hurt me
so they heard her
damn the weight I don't know
what Maria died for out there
but whatever it was
don't let it be for nothing
fix this Fury I really love that we
get to see this side of Nick Fury while
the NATO Secretary General says NATO is
acting swiftly to gather Intel on the
bomb scroll
that's for what the Kremlin regards as
an all-out declaration of war by the
Americans they're all saying we
there's no way that Moscow attack was
committed by Americans this has got
false flag written all over it he's
gonna come back Shooter McGavin always
comes back how did you know Fury would
be there
it didn't
but I hoped
I wanted to see how much of him was left
you know I could have killed him if I
wanted to damn he's taking Delight in
this just get me to the council meet
I want to see their faces while moscow's
still burning
I wonder how much of this mission is
imbued in Revenge
I like the client confidence of this guy
this actor he's got such a baby face I
think it works for him because like
there's so much malice and then you've
got like this cherubickness yeah there's
duplicitousness about it the duality of
his face really
I don't know
shoot him in the head
all dressed up in the man's finery
drinking the man's wine
playing the minds game using the man's
Falcon knife
better to behave as a human than as a
dog they're all Scrolls
what the hell gives you the right to
disobey this counsel Michigan yet
I like how so much of the show is about
consequences and reaction and failures
of the heroes we followed yeah it's
really cool I think it's a war
and what happens if the Avengers return
put your facing me
I promise Avengers really are gone huh
yeah they're all over the place now we
need a single Commander whose war power
is total and unchecked my God therefore
I nominate graphic
yep I'm the commander of NATO I can
mobilize a million troops at this level
whoa
all it takes is one now I know what to
do in live streams when John doesn't
shut up
[Music]
in our history we ended up homeless
refugees because we were too willing
I will not support your War
I am ready to die
you're gonna be sister
you'll not be harmed
respect
I don't agree with this it's not like
the humans have been opposing or
segregating the Scrolls and most of them
don't even know you're here yeah
and we've seen some crazy lately
let's try us
Green Scene than purple scene
and a blue scene and a red scene
posing colors duality
he has control of our people and our
future we're gonna have this
conversation with that guy right there
yeah
that's nice graphic has changed
someone's dead but if you can't keep it
together you will not walk out alive
surely keep it together gravel on his
voice
Harvest wasn't there
graphic has given me multiple locations
for the Harvest all of them empty
like someone's having trouble keeping
promises too
what is that what are they building I
hope it leads to a big CGI battle
kind of Rhodes
Terence Howard
next time
I can't take the authenticity of Russian
supplied photos at face value however I
will be more than happy to have them
analyzed at our facilities at Langley
saying about our photos
how do you explain Mr Fury's presence in
Moscow alleged presence Madam Slovakia
rolls the size of me one more time I'm
gonna put on the suit and carpet bombing
careful surely president ritzen is aware
of the seriousness until such time as
you can present an actual shred of
evidence to back those concerns up I'm
afraid sensitivity is all you're going
to be getting from us well handled Brody
I would just always use I helped defeat
Thanos I saved all of you so shut up I
assume Armani
it's pretty expensive for a government
salary yeah well my other suits made of
titanium so this actually constitutes
considerable savings
Croatia talking crap Slovakia
or carpet bomb there it is
one o'clock
do me a favor and try not to pop off a
nuclear Holocaust before you get there
one of the post-credits scene of the
season is just him carpet bombing
Slovakia faces all over CCTV footage I
was there trying to stop the attack
meaning you not only set the stage for
World War III but you simultaneously
flipped all of our allies to Team Russia
nice one Fury
how well do you know your security
detail what if I told you they were all
spies Hydra yeah if Hydra was a bunch of
green guys who could shape-shift into
your daddy just say Scrolls man
I don't think he knows that Don knows or
Brody knows so how long have you known
about them
eyes only top secret presentation the
Pentagon was concerned that they might
get into their heads to invade us one
day from the inside
oh
is real
that's not possible that's what I
thought too but it's true it's a secret
maybe we should call our friends we get
them in a fight with the Scrolls and
next thing you know they find themselves
duplicated and turned into terrorists
Fury this is my War we're 80 are there
okay I'm not doing it are you really
talking to me about politics right now
I'm here as an Envoy of the United
States government Fury the job is
political I remember when your job was
protecting the planet it's like Civil
War stuff right here
we owe each other so let's make the
power mean something Apple growth out
cars outside colonel
this conversation's gone far enough
Colonel these men are going to escort
you outside then you're going to the
airport have you even listened to a word
that I've said the enemy is a million
times more dangerous than Hydra but they
can only be vanquished by you but you
should know better than most it's just
so well written it really is the point
of this power is to be uncompromising to
be able to sit across from a man we
greatly admire and to tell him without
any reservation
that he's fired whoa whoa oh my God I
want your gun in your badge on my desk
dick Fury Rogue Nation yes
is it you to fire me I volunteer that
mess that you created in Moscow that
resulted in getting one of our best
people murdered you earned all this
smoke
brother brother
wow woof I can't wait for the armor War
show and I'm so excited can't wait to
watch Roadie debate people just because
you shook me in my titles I relinquished
my DNA
whoa ouch
and you wonder why you're out I'm Nick
Fury even when I'm out
I'm in
a great lover
s
[Music]
daddy Fury that was such a well-written
scene this show is so well written I'm
so impressed it's like the Andor of the
MCU yeah
yes and now that the door is unlocked
what does that tell you about me and
doors
[Laughter]
imagine if this came out after end game
and like this is such a good sequel to
where we left things
if your mother ever warn you could lose
an eye by beating your meat like that
where is the escape hatch in this dump
why do you need to know that oh just a
hunch
well now that's confirmed oh my
that's where she started the
interrogation I was not I did not think
they would share something like that
yeah it was a high crop dude
good implication oh my God
foreign
I thought to myself what kind of coward
sends his daughter to do what he
wouldn't but you know then I realized
that kind of cow would just
doesn't have it in him well you don't
know that coward I'll never talk to you
that's very brave but everyone talks
when their blood starts to cook at 160
degrees Centigrade
the smart one start talking earlier than
that I you're a smart one
are you a smart one
wow that works fast
not kill them I think it does but they
get stuff first maybe what's he gonna
become tell me the location of Graphics
compound we swear I don't know nothing
please grab a game something a secret
and what Secrets doesn't he keep Tell Me
Something I Don't Know
he's building a machine what kind of
machine
I think it's to make us stronger
super perhaps who's leading the science
it's a married couple
what's their name
please
read Richard
sorry but if I didn't get a name I won't
get the chance to kill you oh boy
this does look painful the name's
dolphin
oh you see that wasn't so terribly
difficult was it
I know the sausage is gonna explode
oh
nice good timing yes this is Matt
but also damn it that's a really
effective silencer damn it is so silent
you can't even hear the glass break
it silences everything silence
thank you
sounds like your lift is here
escape hatch
nice good throw
oh oh leather faced them
[Music]
it's like actual blood effects cool
Dostoyevsky
laughs
well done I got him let's go
nothing just lies just lies
that's all I swear
look at him and say that yeah you looked
at the floor
keep driving
let's define our safe house
oh
let me make it home pain
almost there bro
come here I want to show you something
oh that shot
getting to you listen to your conscience
I really like how the scrolls are just
portrayed like people people trying to
get by like they need guns and
everything you know they're also that
he's the one that is allowed like
allowed to have a gun they're always
giving it back to him like he's that
leader yeah dictator
wow
oh interesting was I right I think your
vitamins was I right
he was shacked up with a scroll
Fury
good for Nick Nick scrolly
aren't you forgetting something
all right run back out to the store
hahaha who have you been out seeing
almost
that's what I'm talking about that's
right let's get some romance go wood
Fade to the bedroom
damn
what Colby Smulders appearing in a box
yeah I was like I don't think they even
showed her physically nah but they
mentioned her
they mentioned her name
man that was good
that was great man
that was scrolltastic quality I wish
there are like 10 episodes of the show
how many episodes are going to be
because it's great it's just these two
shows over Nick Fury goes home to his
wife who's done
yeah as I got fired oh man I kept
thinking in this episode that
uh if this would had come out like like
year after end game and if we had like
less stuff in between like what a
different conversation there would be
because this feels like such a cool
sequel to The paranoia of the dusting to
like trauma there's so much remorse it's
just so good yeah it's really well done
really well done
Jonathan oh man I cannot agree more I'm
very intrigued like the second this the
second I got the sense you know that the
episode was ending I was like ah damn
like both of these had that quality of
like I don't want to stop watching and I
love that I mean there has been physical
Stakes there has been action there have
been deaths and things but so much of it
is just debate which is uh great
especially when something like this can
compel with that I'm really impressed
that the action choreography is as good
as it is alongside how good the dialogue
is I feel like a lot of times with shows
you kind of have to choose like the
directing either
um uh lends itself to good conversation
action or the directing lens itself to
good action but the the style of the
cinematography doesn't feel too
disparate when it changes from an action
scene to a a dialogue scene but it
allows for both to feel authentic
because it doesn't have that green grass
quality where it's like I don't know
what's happening and I love green grass
because that works for that world but it
wouldn't work here whereas this is like
a nice whole to the choreography has to
be so tight that it looks plausible well
yeah and the way they shoot this stuff
is like it has a nice visual style but
it's not overly flashy either yeah you
know well I think with the action too
they wanted to be reflective of who the
characters are what's our main what's
our main guy's name again uh graphic
graphic yeah with graphic
uh even with him just showing how John
Wick tactile he is demonstrates doesn't
waste time how big of a position he like
not only is he the strategist and the
great
great manipulator he is also
um The Ultimate Warrior of them all you
can see how much he has trained himself
to become who he is and you see that's
really demonstrating so not only is he a
mental threat that you have to go up
against but he's also a physical threat
that you have to compete with at the
same time and I love the layers that
they have shown with him because he he
he's the one who's inspiring the people
the scrollopolis
I like to call it he's the one inspiring
them yet you get these shades of
conniving
Menace and villainy you know piercing
through these little smirks that he has
so it's like I I I I haven't really
gotten a full sense of what like he just
seems like he wants domination like he
just wants to run whatever it is there
is no there is no remorse as they point
out for this character like there were 2
000 people who were killed and it is an
interesting conversation they're having
because you know they're factoring in
the history of what brought the Scrolls
here to Earth and they're kind of
forgetting a lot of what initially got
them there in the first place and this
invasion is not something where you know
they're retaliating because of how
they've been treated right you know like
most people don't even know about them
yeah they they are just kind of
dominating and it is it is really cool
where it's so different from the comic
in every way because like the Scrolls
the comics are like loud just like big
letters yeah
we're aliens yeah we're aliens we've
come to destroy you people you know
um but I love just the humanistic
portrayal that they're they're giving
here uh it's it's very interesting it
really suits this medium and I I always
talk about what like adaptation versus
translation is for Comics to shows this
is such a better take for this medium I
think when you have an event comic you
need a bad guy so in the comic books you
need like green aliens that are yelling
about alien stuff but in a show that
wouldn't work and in a show that's this
well written you can really make it
about violence and refugees and history
and it really is a great commentary and
so many of our things by looking at our
problems from an outside lens and I
loved like the the subverting
expectations of like having graphic let
her go when she decided not to join the
coup I thought that was genius too
show
mercilessness towards violence uh
failing and show seeming Mercy towards
like I understand where you're coming
from and that makes it much more
interesting than the choice of like okay
she dies and and then the rest of the
time you've got this fear and
intimidation and he really seems like
he's wanting to help his people because
of that letting her go as opposed to him
just being a malevolent dictator because
he mostly is yeah I love what they're
doing with the whole scroll Community
yeah and it's interesting too that with
Nick Fury uh and a lot of the
conversation was even brought up as well
with Roadie how they are factoring I
feel like this is the first time with
Nick fear that they're actually
exploring the fact that he's black you
know and going in through a lot of the
history and the struggles and the
impression as well of wanting to belong
as well and wanting to be accepted yeah
and they're they're using that lineage
in a way that is semi-reflective of
what's going on with the Scrolls as well
which I thought they did a good job with
Miss Marvel with when they when they
tied in like Muslim culture and Muslim
Heritage with where we're leading with
mutants where they made it a commentary
on feeling othered being outside and
then like this is doing it with
historically American treatment of
things and I like the the those two
paths being like guys look at what we've
done there are ramifications but not
being I mean there's people going to
complain but but not being in a way that
feels like it's the only purpose of it
like it feels like it serves the story
not uh it has to be the story yeah and
also like with Nick Fury and Rhody in
that conversation when that topic was
brought up of that doesn't mean that we
should just give each other a pass just
because we have difference of beliefs
that we have to you know just agree to
these things because like Roadie's
stance is so like drastically different
on this matter yeah
um that was a great again I'm a big fan
of like when you write a really strong
debate and I think this this show I mean
they had two great scenes here uh two
great Powerhouse scenes with Nick Fury
where him and Talos at the very
beginning on the on the train yeah
feeling like they're being light like
you know being lied to and also were
tell us tell us or Talos it's a falcon
or Falcon um
in the show they seem to be going with
Talos in the movie I thought it was
Talos but well Nick Fury says Talos so I
suppose I should alter my pronunciations
yes Carlos actually Carlos but yeah
we're talos's anger was coming out as
well like I think these act they got so
many is it Olivia Coleman an
oscar-winning actress too then she went
I think so in the last five years I
think she won an Oscar as well yeah I
don't think Ben Mendelson's won but he's
not he should yeah he's one of the best
um but to have just these actors here
and they and like Don Cheadle too who is
also an Oscar nominated too this was
like man we're really finally those
Roadies usually just like he's cool
right and I'm always like you guys have
donkey yeah
and that's my biggest issue with the MCU
of of like the the 15-year run and
sometimes they cast so well that I'm
like it's not cheating yeah like can you
can you let donji utilize what their
range is truly capable of and what
everything Brewing underneath the
surface we want to see that come out and
I think they capture that with Nick Fury
and Taylor's on the train and that's why
you do the show yeah like this is what I
feel like you could have gotten these
scenes in a movie too no I don't think
like look we've already spent two hours
they'd be over like this is what
happened at the one hour mark no but
this is episode two I know but it
happened at the one hour market for
factoring in the runtime of when those
scenes occurred sure but I don't want
that to be the whole thing like this
would be the end of the movie we'd be
done and I think that the reason you do
television is because Comics are
serialized so you can have a slow burn
build up and I think that that when when
they announce the Marvel Cinematic
Universe shows tying into the movies and
saying this is gonna be one big universe
I thought it was for stuff like this
like this is what you can build and I
think this you need these actors to get
more time to play this is why donofrio
is one of the best villains because you
let Kingpin be as captivating as
Daredevil now we've got an entire
Invasion that's just as interesting as
the Thanos subplot that took 10 movies
to build to like this is why you do TV
yeah I completely agree and the budget
allows for you to sit in a room and talk
and also the uh it forces you too also
um and and also how it's dealing so much
with the ramifications of Nick Fury's
choices yes of not helping out and you
could tell there's that guilt like he
does feel solely responsible for it and
I even thought the justification of not
calling in The Avengers was like that is
so smart yeah what are you gonna do the
face normally uh like I think in the
trailers or something they were like nah
this is this is what something I gotta
do it's my personal mission yeah but
when you're seeing the trailers with
like a bunch of action and you're
like I don't know man calling the
Avengers
like you're putting more people in
danger by just doing this yourself kind
of selfish yeah um but the conversation
that he had with uh Roadie there I was
like damn that is so well Justified of
why not to call it the event one of the
best in comic book mediums to not have
like everything always be an Avengers
level event it's always so frustrating
when you've introduced these characters
like you've got their phone number like
and then this one did that but in a way
that feels like it serves not only the
medium but also uh the the tone but you
can tell how it could build to an
Avengers level 100 if not
um uprooted properly or perhaps a
Fantastic Four Level Threats perhaps
some super skrills are introduced in
this maybe they're building Fantastic
Four
could have like it actually feels like
that that when they introduced that orb
it feels like maybe that's them building
a super scroll thing well yeah what they
they show like when they're going
through the extremist and the Groot that
there's gonna be scroll through upgrade
that's what I think is really cool about
this is because right now what we're
seeing as Scrolls when they're just
humanistic they you know they need guns
they need all these other things but
they don't have superpowers rather than
shape-shifting yeah and then and then
eventually they're going to evolve the
evolution of mutation with scientific
level so it's not like uh natural
mutation but they're going to infuse it
with stuff so that's what they were
setting up right that's what I gathered
yeah and I feel like this tone is is
gonna make it so when we have them in a
movie that's only like you know your 90
minute two hour We're invested in the
origin of how they got cool as opposed
to the comics or the cosmic rays maybe
like it's just like this is more
exciting for me to make it more
plausible but like in this tone and
genre
yeah that it's great stuff great stuff
John you guys grow on you yeah a little
bit it's funny and she didn't speak
heartly at all but I actually kind of
liked just being able to observe her
body language and yeah she did feel uh
you know more engaging to me and sort of
alive here as you watch her you know
flip back and forth between like oh
maybe graphic is going a little too hard
at this but also I'm still dedicated to
the cause so uh so yeah it's not a Gaia
Rich episode necessarily but I did uh
find myself a little bit more interested
in her just you know Journey from here
and and two I really appreciated that
they start the episode in 95 and then
you jump to 97 and you see the warping
you know 99.
but maybe we'll see the metrics but I
like that you know it's like we're you
know 30 odd years on from that in the
timeline and and you know at the start
of a movement like this at the start of
a refugee situation like this the
sentiments are different and then you
can see how they would warp change
complacency can set in for one group of
a group within the group and then you
have characters like gravic who you can
see this has sort of festered over time
to the point where they you know he has
developed this extreme uh philosophy and
I think that that's just another you
know nice way too to complement the idea
of yeah you have Roadie and fury
discussing generational things and
cultural things multiplied by gaps in
generation and you have a similar
different but similar thing happening
with the Scrolls there too that also
applies to a character like Gaia and I
like that the time works because Samuel
Jackson in real life has dealt with all
that like the Samuel Jackson's real
story is staggering and like when he was
a child like all the things that he was
involved with in his lineage his parents
and it's cool to have an actor that it
really puts timelines in perspective
like how recently things were even more
in our world and so to have the
Scrolls go back to the 90s you know
that's 30 years ago now so we're gonna
have multiple generations of them
feeling oppressed we're gonna have
multiple generations of like them
growing up so it's more Justified that
they're gonna have this war they're
trying to cook up so I like tying in you
know Samuel Jackson who's lived through
so much his story feels so authentic and
then like these I'm glad the Scrolls
were set in the 90s is what I'm saying
I'm glad Captain Marvel was set long
enough ago that there's like this Slow
Burn percolation like this thing that's
boiling under the surface it's not like
hey they landed they're mad they're
aliens it's like no no we've not done
the thing we promised they've been in
hiding and and like the kids of them are
never going to know Freedom like that
our our villain was a child who who came
to this angry he set all that time to
train to become angry to become this
leader become this thing and he's
justified in his feeling oppressed I
think it's really beautiful parallel
storytelling he almost said percolating
German s
but you know what's also cool is uh it's
not Duality I was gonna try and segue
that way but him him talking to Telus
and telling the story about tell me what
is something I don't know that reminded
me that pulled me all the way back to
what is that Civil War when he's telling
the story about his I can't remember now
it's like his dad or somebody or
somebody he used to know who would like
walk this bag of he would like deliver a
bag every night and then you know the
the story grow I'm not going to
paraphrase it well here but he that was
your dad's story that was my that's your
life I wish Nick Fury was my dad and I
think maybe Age of Ultron I do know what
you're talking about
um and like that he tells that he
relates a personal story that does go on
as like a monologue that then and
factors into the overall point in a way
that does feel it was one of those
things where I'm like oh yeah he is like
a person with experience yeah that's
just a cool guy well what stood out to
me in the opening credits was when it
said executive produced by Sam Jackson
sure and I did not know that I didn't
either I wish I had and I feel like he
really got involved I agree actually
making sure this character felt more
human and fleshed out uh because this is
easily shaping up to be the best Nick
Fury portrayal so far from Samuel
Jackson
um because you get so many it doesn't
feel like they're doing a rewrite on the
character it just feels like you're
getting a better understanding of the
character you know what I mean like
you're seeing like these softer sides to
him these more compassionate sides and
in some ways like that the more the more
Humanity angles of him seem to have come
through with the relationships that he
formed with the scroll
and boy we're even married one you know
uh I think that's awesome because he's
usually around humans he even talks
about like humans can't even get along
you know yeah you you see how with that
with whatever he's interacting with
humans it just seems so like freaking
tough and on edge
is a hard ass but the softer side comes
out of him which was set up in Captain
Marvel but now you're seeing it in the
show even more so that there is some
there is that softer human to this guy
yeah and now we get to really see that
in a way that doesn't feel like it's
undoing the Nick Fury that we know
totally agree sometimes when you change
a character that much it's like wait are
they playing the same character this
feels very natural so we write them for
television
or like it's got to fit this narrative
huh yeah it's not that I I think they've
done a great job with a lot of these
things that I felt like Falcon and
Winter Soldier were trying to do but
they're making it more interesting and
better action all the time well and they
don't seem like they're shying away from
things that overlap with real world
conflicts the Wake Falcon Winter Soldier
like literally removed aspects like that
and and even like there's elements to
the Scrolls that remind me of the flag
Smashers but this is better done
um this is a lot of things I wanted that
show to land yeah so far also Alfred
Woodard uh I as Charlene Woodard like
related I have no idea Priscilla I
assume it's his wife uh I don't know if
we got her name but the scroll guard
played by Luke J Smith related to Will
Smith I mean they must be no but like a
woodard's not not as common as Smith and
she also like has a presence too I'm
just wondering if Alfred Woodard has
like a sibling uh John
um I loved Olivia Coleman's um the
violence that comes out within her I
love what do you think about Olivia
Coleman she was terrific I she it's I
think it's an easily it's easy to fall
into being the Trope of being yeah like
ooh Charming bubbly but also ruthless
but I think she just she is such a good
actress that she makes me believe that
even though I'm waiting to see you know
for we've only had a couple scenes with
her and so far it's all you know what
she shows to the outside I'm curious to
see what's underneath but I think she's
killing it right now and her scenes are
a really nice change of tone because it
brings all that Menace but she's just a
fun and and quirky to watch
um and I love that they have her Talent
here as well and I can't wait to see
just her role increase in all of this
because she's clearly very capable I
loved how we've set up gravic and
I'm trying to find her name
Sonia Sarah kravik and Sonia
um but you only see them from the
political side first and then this
episode towards the end you get to see
what they're like in the field when
they're getting their hands dirty yeah
yeah it's really neat they've done a lot
of really cool stuff with this I'm
really impressed with this this is like
the kind of drama I would put on and
watch at home by myself
I'm not gonna lie I'm not gonna lie at
one point I was so in the show I was
like do I want to just watch this like
not work like and I don't usually feel
that way I'm like I'm like do I want to
just like not be doing it this way but
like I really like sharing an art but
this Show's so good I'm like I feel like
it's for me yeah I love that like this
is all the things I liked about Loki
where it's the two-person conversations
that I loved in Loki but with an even
more sizable ensemble cast of Powerhouse
so that can all do that kind of work
that Owen Wilson and Tom Hiddleston did
yeah so I mean if this sticks The
Landing it's definitely on the top three
hope to God it sticks The Landings right
now it's really setting itself apart
it feels so different in all the right
ways and I'm just getting worried that
they're gonna pull that Disney plus
finale episodes
we were so close to it yeah dropping the
ball if it does though man yeah this is
this is top tier Marvel because the
pacing is on point and the writing is
really strong and the acting is so good
that I'm like I don't want to over
compliment you just yet because I've
been down this road before yeah
uh but really maybe that's Marvel this
it it could like it feels like
real
uh High reference feels like a real
movie
It's a drama like they've they've really
committed to it being a drama and it
doesn't feel like they're trying to do
any audience satisfaction it
definitely feels like a Prestige
Showtime or HBO drama it feels like a
Prestige show that happens to somehow
have green aliens in it like it's so
good it's like the Americans you know
like the show is the Russians yeah oh
yeah yeah
um is that Kerry Russell Clara Danes I'm
totally forgetting is on homeland home
oh no yeah but also you know yeah
yeah yeah
um yeah guys what'd you think about this
episode leave your thoughts down below
uh be sure to subscribe and leave a like
and uh follow us on patreon and we'll
Adelia Chamberlain Adelia if there's
anyone who's a scroll at our patreon
page it's a hundred percent you I see
what's happened in this world of YouTube
I see you now working for a bunch of
these different people all the time it's
an invasion it's an invasion that's what
you've done you've come in here
pretending under the guys that you're
just a fan no no no you don't have this
sheepish
shy timid woman you're far from that
that was all a con all and act a Comic
Con you might say it was all
no so that way you could weasel your way
in and then boom get this new career
working with the top dogs and the big
leagues
and what I say to you
Bravo well done respect they
don't hate the player
hey the game
and man I love the player here oh yeah
you play us awesome you know how to do
it it's a new form of female seduction
is what you've pulled off here and I
find it very impressive Adelia gosh
we need more Scrolls like you in this
world who know how to insidiously invade
their way in because you don't want to
be obvious about it you knew how to do
it in a way where no one would ever
suspect and I could learn a thing or a
lot of people could learn a thing or two
from you
oh yeah and you earned all of it because
you're actually good at what you do yeah
whatever
A lot of people are good at stuff
proficient no but do quality work
being that awesome scroll uh-huh
love you dear
[Music]